that's the way
tonight the bourbon room stacey jacks
this place is about to become a sea of
sweat hear shadowy music and puke
so start drinking
now let me know
now go
your first album gave birth to some of
rock's greatest anthems what's it like
to be the stacey jacks
stacy you made it amen hey man now this
is amen
amen
when i was a kid i wanted to be stacy
this club is totally out of control
our whole existence is riding on stacey
jacks we're gonna shut them down
oh my god i just threw up well in my
pants
you want love go after i can guarantee
you something more cool
if you want to get respect you got to
take that stage
on fire
stacy jacks he gives until it
so put hurts diamond that you bought